this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thanks Neal well good
afternoon everyone and thank you for
coming you know it really means a great
deal to me that you would show up today
to hear about this presentation on the
work that I've been conducting over the
past two years so I often get asked the
question why would you work on a crop
that is so small and well so meaningless
and when I first came into this I asked
myself where do I want to go and where
do I want to take this degree and one of
the first things that came to mind was
work with a traditional green house
cultivated crop such as tomatoes or
lettuce and doing some work with
lighting or production systems as a
whole but as I became more introduced
into New York's greenhouse industry I
became so infatuated with just how many
growers are less than ten thousand
square feet
about 85% to be exact that I got this
urge to help the little guy
so as Neil my adviser took me around
various operations I began to see this
trend in the cultivation of these
microgreens now one of these growers we
visited let's call them Timothy farms
started asking Neil and I questions
about these crops and the difficulty
they were having and producing them so
so when we went to visit these
subsequent operations days and our weeks
and months to follow I began to notice
that regardless of experience or size
growers were struggling with reliably
producing these crops and it became very
apparent very quickly that the source of
this trouble stemming from factors many
of us often take for granted in
well-established crops just being simple
production protocols now this is where
my work really began and is well defined
in my thesis as two distinct chapters
chapter one
really
focused on this idea of establishing
optimal cultural practices for the
production of these crops
these were seed density substrate depth
fertilizer concentration with nitrogen
being the focal point for adjustment and
air temperature once I establish optimal
cultural practices that resulted in
reliable growth
I started chapter two of my research
which looked at the effects of varying
daily light integral and carbon dioxide
concentration on the growth of these
crops now before I really begin and dive
into the work that I've been conducting
we need to step back for a moment and
define what microgreens truly are now
most people know the difference between
sprouts and baby leaf greens and really
the best way to define a micro green is
by sticking them right between those two
crops in short a micro green is just a
vegetable or herb harvested shortly
after emergence of the first true leaf
or leaves but prior to true leaf
development and senescence of the
cotyledons now one of the drivers for
growers to start producing these crops
is their high-value this falls in the
range of roughly 65 to 110 dollars per
kilogram and fresh weight which can be
highly incentivizing for growers as a
supplementary income source however
because their growing period only goes
between 10 to 20 days they are
considered a protected cultivation crop
due to their sensitivity and with very
little known about these crops there's
only a handful of publications primarily
focusing on their nutritional content
and the effects of variations in light
regimes now the image on this slide is a
prime example of the variability you can
find in microgreens where this
particular example does not meet the
attributes of the definition I just put
forth now you might be asking yourself
what is the
I heard for this crop that is so small
yet so expensive well I did not conduct
any consumer preference research there
have been numerous publications across
various social outlets praising the
health promoting benefits of microgreens
and the elegance that they impart on any
dish in fact this article by NPR is one
of the most accurate representations of
the crop that I could find serving as a
healthy side of science with your micro
green salad
now experiments to establish the various
cultural practices on the growth
morphology and days the harvest of these
crops were really targeted towards the
grower what this meant was that the
experiments that we wanted to devise
needed to be obtainable by the average
small-scale grower as I pointed out
earlier these manifested and treatments
for seed density substrate depth
fertilizer concentration and air
temperature now the reason why this is
important is because when you purchase
seed from a seed company the
recommendations made by the various seed
companies vary widely in addition these
recommendations are not species or genus
specific nor do they vary by seed size
or plant growth habits so when you
receive your seed in the mail the back
of the package has a general descriptor
recommending an average of 1.1 seeds per
square centimeter growing area and 2
temperature recommendations 24 degrees C
for germination
and 16 degrees C for growth but what
happens if the growers temperatures are
not within those recommendations what
about if the growers media is expensive
whose isn't and they want to get the
best bang for their buck with many
microgreens sold in the containers in
which they are grown in there is no room
for poor stand development so over or
under seeding can result in unappealing
product now these pictures here are just
a small subset of images that I have
stored on my computer from growers who
struggle with struggle with reliably
producing these crops
simply because they don't know where to
start the image on the top is from an
aquaponics operation this as you can see
is struggling from seed density issues
irregular development rates and in
numerous flats extensive disease
pressure the image on the bottom is from
an operation that truly believed that
fertilizing these crops was unnecessary
so I initially started with 15 different
species and through trials I narrowed it
down to three distinct species now there
are a number of reasons why I chose
three and only three but they were
primarily chosen due to their presence
and local markets similarity and feed
size and number of days from seeding to
harvest and variability and sensory
attributes while there are upwards of 70
different varieties to choose from
I chose only three based on limitations
and experimental design from a hardware
standpoint as you will see in my
discussion of the DL I in co2 component
in my research so the first parameter
that I really looked at with seed
density when you purchase a bag of seed
from Johnny seed for example they
recommend an average of 1.1 seeds per
square centimeter of growing area now
when I utilize this rate I noticed that
it happened to result in a lot of unused
media which in turn resulted in a
relatively sparse canopy given the cost
of substrate seed and other input
variables I wanted to find that optimal
density that resulted in greatest growth
so I investigated five different seeding
densities four of which corresponding to
50 percent increments in density above
the recommended rate what we found was
the population fresh weight increased in
a quadratic fashion for all three
species as see density increased from
one point one to three point three seeds
per square centimeter on the flip side
four escalate per plant decreased in a
quadratic fashion for all three species
as seed density increase from one point
one to three point three seeds per
square centimeter
now this is something that we expected
to see due to competition for resources
such as light and growing space but we
did not start to see this reduced
population yield component until 2.5
times the recommended seeding rate now
this is really great for growers because
it allows them to get the best it allows
them to get the best bang for their buck
and make the most out of their bench
space even though this factor reduced
population even though this fresh way
per plant decreased that had no
noticeable effect on the maturity rate
of the crop so regardless of your
density that crop is sitting on the
bench for the same amount of time so
it's besting utilised that space as
efficiently as possible
the next factor we looked at or the next
factor looked at with substrate depth as
I visited growers in the area I happen
to notice that many of them only utilize
the small fraction of the volume of a
standard 10 by 20 inch tray with
substrate depths often as shallow as
only one to two centimeters now the
principle behind using less substrate is
feasible because let's face it these
crops are only growing for 10 to 20 days
after which all those inputs are then
composted but given these crops high
density and high competition for
resources it may be using less substrate
may be counterproductive to their growth
now as a result I looked at four
different substrate depths ranging from
one point eight two five two point eight
centimeters per cell or roughly 86 to
278 cubic centimeters per cell the
response is fresh weight to increasing
substrate depth was positively quadratic
what was really interesting was that
there was no statistical difference
between species or their response to
changes in substrate depth now this
happens to be very convenient because
obtaining a substrate depth at container
capacity at a more
at Adam at a capacity at four point
three centimeters also happens to be
roughly the same as if you fill the
container to container
fill the container to about height using
bad moisture content media and
subsequently water into container
capacity however this one line fits all
response was not reciprocated in dry
weight where the effects of substrate
depth was not only linear but also
varied by species with arugula having a
30% greater response to increases in
substrate depth than mizuna or mustard
now this was not uncommon though at the
lack of collinearity between fresh and
dry weight as you will see was also
observed in other treatments a trend
that is shared with other a trend that
was shared with other literature
regarding the relationships between
fresh and dry weight it is work it is
worth however noting that might good for
sales of microgreens fresh weight is the
preferred you'll determine it so as a
result greater weight is placed on that
parameter now one of the important
observations that was noted in this
experiment was the tendency for either
the lowest or substrate or highest
substrate depths to exhibit either rapid
moisture loss as was the case with the 1
point 8 centimeter treatment or
excessive water holding capacity as was
the case with the 5 point 8 centimeter
treatment this means that growers need
to have a stronger grasp on their
irrigation scheduling or the if they
already utilize either of these two
treatment levels to avoid the potential
of extensive process now you know in
greenhouse operations it is an
undeniable fact that fertilizer cost of
fertilizer regardless of its source the
organic or inorganic is a required input
for the successful growth of plants
however microgreens load short
production period does allow them to be
produced in the absence of supplemental
fertilizers unfortunately this
trait is often to the detriment of their
production as many growers interpret
this is not needing to fertilize even if
a fertilizer sources on hand in the same
greenhouse for other crops for this
experiment I wanted to look at the
effects of fertilizer concentration
using a constant liquid feed of twenty
one two point two twenty one to point to
sixteen point six NPK at five nitrogen
fertilizer concentrations zero 50 100
150 and 200 milligrams nitrogen per
liter
now this experiment was designed to take
advantage of the constant liquid feed
systems that are already in place in
most greenhouse operations and will be
utilized at each irrigation interval
results were nearly identical to that of
the only other publication on micro
green nutrition and very similar to that
of mature and comparable crops such as
lettuce we're fresh way increased in a
quadratic fashion as fertilizer
concentration increased from zero to 200
milligrams nitrogen per liter with
reduced gains in fresh weight above 100
to 150 milligrams nitrogen per liter now
this response also varied by species
with arugula where arugula had a more
strong stronger response to changes in
fertilizer concentration unfortunately
concentrates the moods in our mustard
unfortunately many operations only have
one or two proportioning fertilizer
proportioning units so it may be
necessary to standardize with a single
fertilizer concentration now dry weight
also exhibited the same species
variation however under the influence of
a positive linear model instead of a
quadratic one you can see in the images
that the drastic difference is between
zero and two hundred milligram nitrogen
per nitrogen per liter treatment where
these zero milligram treatment has
substantially less gross than a 200
milligram treatment which in the case of
arugula produced an almost undesirable
proliferation of growth at the highest
treatment level which could intrude on
surrounding cells making harvest more
difficult
now depending on how we define protected
cultivation the large variety of
structures utilized to provide this
function vary considerably in their
insulating properties for small growers
with seasonal more seasonal type
structures increased heating costs can
influence them to change their heating
point thresholds reducing them now which
can have a significant effect on crop
development rate amongst other factors
with microgreens brought timing is
crucial to sales as development rates
are rapidly changing during this
exponential growth phase with most
growers selling direct to the consumer
through farmers markets or restaurant
contracts consistency in quality and
delivery times is fundamental to the
success of the operation with this in
mind I investigated four different
temperature treatments and the effects
of days to harvest of microgreens 14 16
20 and 22 degrees C word were chosen as
24 hour growing temperatures where
plants were started at germination and
grown through to harvest at each of the
levels what we found was it as
temperatures increased from 14 to 22
degrees C days to harvest decreased in a
linear fashion hastening production time
by seven days for arugula six days for
mizuna and eight days for mustard now
being able to produce a crop six to
eight days faster is huge if you're
supplying a customer additionally it
allows you to get in more crop cycles
per year which could mean greater
profits another aspect of temperature
control is that regardless of your
setpoint having a consistent temperature
allow us for greater control of crop
timing which permits a consistent which
allows helps with producing a consistent
crop any day of the year now the image
on the bottom left is very telling
because it shows crop development rates
for the 14 16 and 20 degree C treatments
when the 22 degree
see treatment was ready for harvest now
even though this work I investigated
establishes responses for the various
parameters explored in this research I
did not conduct a full factorial
experiment because of this it is unknown
whether interactions between parameters
could have a substantial influence on
the effects on their effects but
regardless of this fact these results
may possess value to growers who wish to
incorporate these responses into their
production protocols for this purpose we
can summarize results individually
optimized results but the expectation
that interactions would not drastically
change the responses based on based on
my findings initial parameters may be to
sow seed at a rate of 2.75 seeds per
square centimeter of growing area
broadcasted over a peat light mix at a
height of four point three centimeters
growers could then fertilize at a rate
of 150 milligrams of nitrogen and
subsequently grow the crop out in a
greenhouse at a 24-hour temperature of
22 degrees C now of course these values
are not set in stone most growers do not
have the luxury of optimizing their
growing environment for these crops but
net but that is perfectly all right
because using the regression model we
are able to make predictions about
values that were not explicitly trialed
in this research so long as the growers
obtainable values all within the range
of treatments explored in each
experiment it can have a very good idea
of the results that they may obtain so
now that I established a small handful
of cultural practices that resulted in
marketable and consistent growth I
wanted to look at others and other
factors too that resulted in increased
growth rates now all of you sitting here
today are probably quite familiar with
the type of climate we have here in
Africa New York the days are the weather
is often gloomy and in the winter months
things are quite short resulting in less
total accumulated light per day now to
the human eye
uses this is more than enough light to
see but for plants these are very low
daily accumulations in fact most species
in this region during this period are
not actively photosynthesizing and are
in a state of dormancy but that is what
a greenhouse permits us the ability to
continue producing crops year-round but
therein lies the problem even though we
are able to protect these crops from the
environment the low levels of light
during this period are often a limiting
factor in plant growth because of this
some growers opt to utilize supplemental
lighting to increase their average daily
photosynthetically active radiation
levels for example in the graph on this
page we have the average daily number of
moles per square meter on the y axis
moles of light per square meter on the y
axis and days of the year and Julian
days on the x axis plotted over the
course of 13 years what you can see is
that although total daily accumulations
are higher during the summer the total
accumulations light during or higher
during the summer months the total
variability across the year is very high
so on a summer on a nice summer day we
can get as high as 65 moles per square
meter but we can also get as low as
around 5 moles now during the winter
these values are much lower as a whole
so on a nice day in winter we can only
get about 15 moles per square meter
but on a very cloudy day
get less than one bowl to put this into
perspective
a crop like lettuce produces maximum
growth at around 17 moles per square
meter per day for microgreens the
tolerance to low light is very high but
they also respond positively to
increased levels of light to about 18
moles per square meter so the issue
arises that when you wish to produce
maximum growth on days when your natural
light is less than one eighteenth of its
neck its potential the vast majority of
your vast majority of your growth is
coming at the expense of electrical
energy
now no matter how you work this the use
of electricity the power electric lights
to feed growth is an expensive
investment so what we did was we looked
at take the total daily accumulated
light levels at four levels of 3 6 9 and
12 moles per square meter per day and
under a full factorial experiment cross
those with 4 co2 concentrations of 400
600 800 and 1000 parts per million to
see if light and co2 had any impact on
yields morphology days to harvest and
secondary metabolite content of these
microgreens now the first response we
looked at was fresh wait as it turns out
the effects of increasing DLI from 3 to
12 moles per square meter per day with
species dependent where mizuna and
mustard increased in a linear fashion
while arugula increased in a quadratic
fashion the important note compared in
addition fresh wait for arugula was also
more responsive to changes in DOI
between 3 and 9 moles per square meter
per day compared to mizuna and mustard
which were not significantly different
from each other now the importance of
co2 in plant growth cannot be
understated sequestering of carbon from
atmospheric carbon dioxide
can significantly influence yields and
in some cases act as a buffer against to
augment against lower daily
accumulations of light what is most
important is that under the correct
conditions co2 can be a far more
economical means of increasing yields in
compared as compared to electricity for
supplemental lighting for microgreens he
effects the effects of increasing co2
from 400 to 1,000 parts per million was
linear for all three species with no
significant difference between them it
was also observed was that at lower
levels of light for example 6 moles
compared to 9 moles a higher C or an
elevated co2 concentration of 1000 parts
per million resulted in equivalent or
greater growth than the luck the higher
light treatment at an ambient co2
concentration of 400 parts per million
for dry weight the response of all three
species was linear as DLI and co2
increased from 3 to 12 moles per square
meter per day and 400 to 1,000 parts per
million much like fresh weight but to a
lesser degree co2 at 1,000 parts per
million could a cos could be utilized to
counteract reductions of three moles at
400 parts per million now the image in
this slide shows arugula as two
different image angles for the top two
images were taken at 3 moles while the
bottom two were taken at 12 moles the
co2 concentrations of 400 to 1000
ordered left to right now while co2 has
shown that it could have a significantly
positive impact on both fresh and dry
weights it did not appear to have an
effect on days the harvest of either
mizuna arugula or mustard four days of
the harvest the only parameter that had
a significant effect was daily like
integral which responded in a negative
quadratic fashion for Aruba for mizuna
and mustard in a negative linear fashion
for arugula
as do I increase from 3 to 12 moles per
square meter per day now this is really
quite interesting because it provides it
adds a level of complexity where the
grower could then decide whether yields
increase yields or the rate of turnover
is more important in their operation for
example if a grower has a contract where
they are required to produce trays that
fall within a designated fresh wait
range then it may make more sense for
them to increase their daily light
integral to hasten production rather
than increasing co2 to simply increase
growth this would allow the grower to
meet their designated fresh wait range
whilst while producing a crop more
quickly which could mean and get paid
more based on a higher volume of
production now the last response I'm
going to talk about with the production
of total phenols now if you novel
compounds have been overwhelmingly
praised for the health-promoting
benefits stay in part on the human body
when ingested this is because in plant
derived food products in all it
compounds constitute the majority of
antioxidants which have been linked to
reductions in various chronic diseases
such as cancers and cardiovascular
diseases now the results that I obtained
were quite interesting because they
appear did it support this populist
ideas that microgreens are more
nutritious than their mature
counterparts for all three species total
phenolic content represented in
milligrams of Gallic acid equivalents
per 100 grams of fresh weight
tissue increased in a linear fashion as
DLI increased from 3 to 12 moles per
square meter per day in addition there
was a significant interaction between D
Li and Co to wear the effects of D Li
increase of co2 concentrations increase
from 400 to 1,000 parts per million but
co2 on its own did not have a
significant effect on total phenolics
among the three species arugula arugula
exhibited the greatest total phenolic
content but was the least responsive to
changes in DL I although my results
showed for example that arugula had
about the same total phenolic content as
its matured counterparts at 105
milligrams
milligrams this was obtained at just 12
moles per square meter per day and one
thousand parts per million
in contrast mature arugula with roughly
the same total phenolic content and
supporting literature was grown at a
deal I have over 20 moles per square
meter per day at ambient co2
concentrations although this model does
not permit an extrapolation to values as
high as 20 moles other supporting
literature on the response of micro
green phenol content to changes in DL I
have shown responses or increases as
high as 30 moles while still seeing a
positive response the issue however is
the variability in the data or the
variability in the literature we're
total phenolic content for the same
species vary widely by publication and
method of analysis because of this it is
hard to draw a definitive conclusion
about the benefits of microgreens over
their mature counterparts but we can say
if the growers can expect their micro
green arugula mizuna and mustard to have
greater total phenolic content if grown
under a DLI of 12 moles in the paracin
2/3 one of the most interesting
conclusions that was made that came out
of this research with the very
consistent tendency for there to be no
significant no statistically significant
difference between the responses of
mizuna and mustard while both were
consistently and significantly different
from arugula this could be due to the
fact that mizuna and mustard although
different species are of the same genus
different from that of arugula
at least within the scope of this
research it may be
possible to treat mizuna and mustard as
the same crop while separately
optimizing parameters for Aruba now one
of the more recent trends in agriculture
is is the production of crops indoors
such as in vertical production
greenhouses or warehouse type plant
factories well I don't want to dive too
deep into this microgreens low light
requirements and significant significant
responses to be increases in co2 could
make it a potentially a potential crop
for indoor production environments such
as in Seoul source lighting facilities
which in the case which is inferior to a
traditional greenhouse within the
continental US from an energy standpoint
now you could ask is this crop just a
fad and is it going to go away when the
market becomes saturated it's tough to
say but with increasing with the first
publication conducted in 2004 this crop
has only been increasing in popularity
with new publications being added on
what seems like a bi-monthly basis
because of this I'm inclined to say that
they are here to stay with that I would
like to thank you for coming I really
appreciate you you know showed up for my
work and I would like to ask if any of
you have any questions at this time
thank you very much yes my first
question is twofold what my first one is
I got really interesting at the phenolic
content what is greatest in roulette and
you mentioned that if you increase
temperature if you get them to grow
faster by almost seven days do you
expect at all a contract to decrease or
that decrease under what light treatment
so under a decrease if you if it grows
faster like if you want
the temperature and Tory faster would
you expect there to be any different
well the feel like content was a
response to a stress factor so as the
crop it gets more light and more photons
of light than it produces more of these
secondary metabolites as a response
increasing temperatures and growing
faster I would probably say it wouldn't
have an effect on the total amount of
phenol accumulation in the light and co2
research those were grown at 24 degrees
C day/night temperatures so having a
colder temperature I would say it
probably wouldn't affect it but I didn't
test that so okay question oh so I know
you said that the literature is sort of
conclusive and it's hard to test the
phenolic content
pitcher plants would have you taken the
mic like the arugula microwave and
allowed it to grow immature and then
turn focusing on content nope so in
literature that's one thing that is
lacking so people have a lot of the work
that initially came out in terms of the
assessment of the total phenolic content
vitamin and carotenoid levels
what they did was people purchase these
micro greens from you know consumers and
then tested these levels against
purchased mature equivalent crops so on
that basis you don't have an idea of
what the total DLI levels temperatures
co2 humidity all those factors were
unknowns
nobody to my knowledge has actually
grown them side by side under the same
conditions under controlled conditions
and then measured those values that
would be the next work that could be
done treat it with the air temperature
did you see any negative impacts on crop
quality over time
temperatures near expose to like any
through the Kernighan sister know so so
which is eric is talking about is in
lettuce we say that seventeen moles was
kind of this target point for production
because if you go over that you start
resulting in tip burn which is related
to calcium and calcium uptake and
transpiration rates so there's ways to
combat that with movement of air around
the head of the lettuce but in
microgreens and even in my knowledge
when the crops are various small with
lettuce crops you don't see that tip
burn when you really promote those high
levels of light so unfortunately what we
didn't go any higher than twelve and
when in most of the greenhouse
situations as i was showing you in
Ithaca the variability in light levels
is so high that there weren't that many
days where we're growing where the light
inside the greenhouse which is lower
than light that's outside anyways due to
losses that those were high enough to
impart any sort of different effects so
in short we didn't see any in terms of
reduced quality effects at the highest
temperature of twenty-two degrees C I
did tend to see more disease development
at that temperature that could be more
due to just there being depending on
which greenhouse you're in there are
variations other crops but you know with
the chamber work that we did which was
at twenty twenty four degrees or twenty
three degrees C actually there was no we
had no disease development so but that
was a much a sterile and by are not
terrible to clean our environment to
start with it depends on which treatment
so because I should go back to this
actually so these this is an image and
this is actually what I talked about
when I reference the limitations and
experimental design for the hardware
standpoint we had the three species
option there each chamber would have a
different air flow rate depending on co2
concentration so the purpose of the
algorithms that run with you know when
to start dosing that's dependent on the
levels of co2 and inside these units
appear on this little math there's a fan
here that distributes the air around
intends to has a variable fan rate that
moves more quickly when there's higher
co2 levels going in so that is a factor
that's a you know level of variability
that's in the data that's unaccounted
for when you're talking about the
cultural practices you kind of end of it
saying that a lot of growers don't have
the luxury of making sure all of them
are standardized yep so if you have a
starting out and trying to grow
microgreens looks like one of the
factors it would be like maybe you
should invest sometimes money and under
this standardized the most important one
that I would say that they need to
standardize is their temperature that
would be simply the most important from
a quality standpoint from reproduce
reproducibility standpoint which would
always go obviously back to the type of
structure they're getting whether it's a
single layer poly house they use more
for seasonal extension or if it's a
double layer poly with insulated air
barrier or if it does something a higher
quality single layer glass they need to
establish those temperature controls
before anything else the next most
important I would say would be seed
density simply because when growers you
know you I didn't give exact recommended
specifications on the variability by
companies but there are companies out
there and I lift this in my thesis
Johnny C is probably the largest
supplier of these crops there are a lot
of other newcomers
I want to say it's Mountain mist company
but they recommend what they say is one
ounce of seed per 10 inch by 20 inch
tray and that it's just unreasonable to
utilize that much seed for that small of
an area so that is something that
growers need to be aware of is to not
necessarily always follow those
recommendations that are given on the
back of the bag because I stated you
know there regardless of what you buy if
you buy beet seed which you can fit you
know five to seven different root seven
arugula seeds within it that volume of a
beet seed they have the same exact
seeding rate so actually kind of
question over here first you're asking
yes my question so you mentioned that
through your graph that Google a-- the
optimal fertilization concentration from
200 milligrams the optimal so for from
the statistical model the optimal is 200
so we'll go back to that my question
could be made a recommendation right so
it seems like the optimal concentration
of 200 but your recommendation was use
150 milligrams yes so the reason for
that is this picture here and picture a
this is arugula and so what happens is
these cells there's 24 of these cells in
an individual trade and you don't have
to grow it like this this is how I grew
it simply to have replicates per tray
some most growers just simply fill up a
shallow tray with substrate to a certain
height broadcast the seed over the
entire thing and then harvest it as a
whole but there's also a lot of
producers that grow it in these type of
situations where they have a tray with
24 cells inside that tray and then they
sell those individual cells individually
over the internet and they ship them out
they take them to farmers markets so
what happens is when you promote that
much fresh wheat development and that
much mass through fertilizer increases
you start to get this to growth that
just becomes completely overwhelming and
what it does is that you can see there
it folds over and it's not an entirely
at lodging situation because the stems
are still intact but they fold over on
the other cells so then when you go in
to separate them and all this is done by
hands is all hand harvesting going with
scissors to separate those cells you all
sudden have intertwined stems and leaves
and those leaves are especially at the
higher fertilizer concentrations are
very soft so yep and so you start to get
torn tissue and bruising of the tissue
so when you for example if you harvest a
crop like this at 100 milligrams or 150
you don't have as much of that intrusion
cell to cell and as such you can
separate them much more easily so even
though you do get more fresh weight
growth and dry weight growth for arugula
at that 200 it's not worth that
trade-off of losing that particular that
amount and one of the interesting things
is is part of this reduction it may not
have been completely quadratic but
because there is that reduction in yield
by losing product through harvests it
could have certainly influenced that
quadratic response but that's not you
can't really get away from that unless
you produce them themselves separated so
from my personal consumer production
standpoint I like to just just the media
options but the way my house you suggest
that people mix ah and not understand
that for for production productions
systemizing production may keep it but
I've seen before has various mats and
sheets and fiber based products so do
something a little bit about yeah so I
move to this picture because this is two
good examples the top image is produced
on a burlap sack what they did was they
floated that over an aquaponics pond so
they have that essentially on I can't
remember the exact mechanism they use to
float it but
that's how they did this they seated it
on this burlap sack and this grower here
this was a standard you know I think
this was a standard peat light type mix
that they used and you know you can see
and there's been a lot of research
actually different producers looking at
these maps some of the work that's been
done in terms of just simply from a
light you know when they look at
different qualities or quantity of light
they utilize these growing mats instead
of peat light mixes there are advantages
and controllability between these
because the for the the LM what I use is
LM 111 which is a standard you know
typical commercial pipe peat light mix
and that does have a starting charge in
it so we are aware of what the
nutritional content of that is to begin
with versus these mats they come with no
no starting charge Muslim are pretty
inert they're you know cation exchange
capacity is often quite low so it allows
a lot of that individual control if
you're doing like a hydroponic type
float environment in terms of yield
variation it you know the difference in
the literature depends some some people
have seen you know equivalent or greater
growth with these mats and but they
utilize a standard you know pete light
mix but they don't you know specify they
don't say how what level they used or
the depth and the problem is is the
fiber type Maps not this particularly
but there's other fiber mats that are
wood based pulps that they compress into
a mat and you open it up you stick it in
the flat it hydrates itself and it rises
to about a centimeter tall at full
saturation water they yeah they have
we've done you know very minor trials
with them not experiencing the best
results they tend to hold water for you
know excessively long periods of time
and seedlings in general are very
susceptible to damping off as these
issues so that ended
be an issue we also liked the ability to
utilize one substrate across just about
all your different crops so it's very
difficult you know if you are ordering
you know materials in your grower you
don't want to be ordering ten different
substrates different types you want to
have a couple substrates from different
suppliers a little bit of redundancy so
you don't have one supplier goes under
you're not out of luck but yeah it's
it's an easy product to get a hold of
many companies produce and versus those
Maps it's only a small handful and
they're also very expensive substrate
portray in this case I actually have the
full numbers here so the total cost per
square meter of production utilizing
this system for the seed and substrate
is four dollars for arugula five dollars
and 41 cents from mizuna and six dollars
and 47 cents for mustard and that varies
primarily based on the rate of what seed
is going for at that time because that's
quick a lot that's pretty variable in
terms of when you check Johnny seed or
other seed companies those prices vary
but when you purchase one of those mats
for example just one tray and you get
six point six trays per square meter
just one tray the substrate for those
different Maps is about a dollar sixty
1.60 cents per and they you can't reuse
them once they're done you throw it away
so there's versus it's about 40 cents or
so for the substrate portray so I never
had to do this this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu